Well, good morning again Church. It is a joy to
gather together. As always. We should
not take this for granted even in the summer and it
is something that we look forward to if you're
new. We would love to get to know you. We want to meet you
if you can muster up the courage to come
and reduce yourself to us. So we'd love to if not yet. We would love to
just get your information on our website. There's a connect card
there would love to to reach out and pray for
you and encourage you how best we can.
But if you've been around Henderson Hills for any length of time, you know
that a couple years ago. We started a journey through the book
of Psalms in the Old Testament. Just one by one one through
150 and we would take normally
the Summers to do that and kind of take 15
years to eventually get through all of them. I think but side
note this summer. We're actually not going to go through this
Psalms. We're gonna go back into the Book of Luke and just look at the The Parables
that Jesus taught there about the secrets of
his kingdom in story form. So we'll
spend time back in the Book of Luke as we have the last few months.
But we've used these Psalms also not just
for Summers but to fit in on holidays or in between
series and it's just again, whatever is the next one
up is the one that we preach and so
that's why we're in today Psalm 49. So take
your copy of God's word and turn with me there the Big Book
of Psalms right about the middle of the Bible. You'll find it.
And we'll be there Psalm 49 by the
way 150 remember in the Book of Psalms. We're
almost a third of the way through which is kind of wild to think if
you've been here for a couple years. You've seen us walk this journey.
now as you're turning there I last week I preached on
giving
this next Psalm up just happens to be about money
as well.
Now it will take a bit of a different angle compared to
what second Corinthians 8 and 9 took last week.
Which talked about the call for every believer to give generously what
we're going to see today.
instead
Is the temporal futility of money?
of wealth
society around us upholds
and celebrates extravagant wealth
celebrities
business Moguls that they're all the successful ones in the
world
even in our area that we live in
wealth can equal importance
but Psalm 49 shows us clearly none of
that lasts.
None of that last that what the world marks as
success is not necessarily successful according to
God.
And we'll see that today. We need to change the
scorecard of what we see success
in life really meaning.
Especially that wealth is not the ultimate measure
of worth and value.
And it does nothing to change the end result
for anyone.
Flat out the truth. Is that all of us?
Will die at some point.
And so just like I said that statement the rest
of this song will sound pretty bleak at times right? Happy
Memorial Day weekend, right this it's gonna
sound pretty it's gonna sound like Ecclesiastes a lot
of this will
Just sounds distressing and hard at times.
So that's part of what we need to understand because the lower that
that gets and the way we feel about that makes this other
truth that we find in Psalm 49 that
much sweeter.
There's something we can't miss today.
Since Psalm 49 will we won't miss
this that that we will see that wealth does not equal
importance. Yes, but the best part of today's sermon you
might need to hang with me a little bit to get there is that death does
not equal the end for those who believe in the Lord?
We might say it this way that neither wealth nor death
has the final word.
Neither wealth nor death has the final word in our lives.
That's what Psalm 49 will show us. So let's look at the first four verses to
begin with.
Hear this all peoples give ear
all inhabitants of the world both low and high
rich and poor together my mouth shall speak wisdom the
meditation of my heart shall be understanding. I will
incline my ear to a proverb. I'll solve my riddle to
the music of the liar.
Now, let's just get the context here. We need to understand who's talking here.
Just look at the heading right above it often. It says
who wrote it. And so this heading says this is a
a congregational singable Psalm or
a song written by the sons of Korah who
were the guys that led the music in the temple?
They were the worship team the songwriters for the people of
Israel and they wrote this one.
Specifically for a reason they will say in
a moment, but their first talking
to who they're talking to right they here listen up.
As they get into the first four verses that introduction says this
is to everyone.
all the inhabitants of the world
now not just all nations right notice. It says all classes
of people you might say both low and
high rich and poor together. No one
is excluded from the truths are
about to share.
Because again the theme of this psalm.
As we get into this is that that some could think that
wealth might play a role in delivering someone
from Pain and death.
That's the the point we'll see here. And so the sons
of Korah look around the world and they see this happening and
we'll see it what they're talking about in a second, but they see all
of this happen and they think okay here are Universal
truths that everyone needs to hear that all
the people all the classes in the world need to understand listen up.
That's what they say here. These verses three and four are talking about this this
wisdom. They gain from looking at the world from understanding what
God wants and they say okay now here, let me
share what I need to share.
So for the people of Israel, that was what they were hearing was saying,
all right, listen up and you'll be able to sing these truths as a congregation
together, but us now a couple thousand years
later.
We get to read these words.
It's almost like God is shouting these truths to us in a
megaphone.
Like the first four verses for them, but for us today God is
screaming at us to remember he's trying
to get her attention to listen to what he's about to say saying
these things are really really important.
And he's talking to you whether you have the
kind of wealth that might tempt you to feel like this.
Or you just want that kind of wealth from somebody else
you want that kind of life.
So he's screaming at us.
To remember and to listen what he's about to
say.
So look at verses 5 through 20, here's what God inspired these authors to
say about wealth and death.
Why should I fear in times of trouble?
When the iniquity of those who cheat me surrounds me those who
trust in their wealth and boast of the abundance of their
riches.
Truly, no, man. Can Ransom another or give to God the price of
his life?
For The Ransom of their life is costly and can never suffice that
he should live on forever and never see the pit.
For he sees that even the wise die.
The fool and the stupid alike must perish and leave their wealth to
others.
Their graves are their homes forever. They're Dwelling
Places to all generations though. They called
lands by their own names when they're alive.
Man in his pump will not remain. He's like
the beasts that perish.
This is the path of those who have foolish confidence.
Yet after them. They the people approve of their
boasts.
Like sheep, they are appointed for sheol. That's the place
of the Dead Death Shall be their Shepherd and the upright shall
rule over them in the morning.
Their form shall be consumed and shield with no place to
dwell.
But God will Ransom my soul from
the power of sheol for he will receive me.
Be not Afraid when a man becomes rich when the
glory of his house increases for when he dies he'll
carry nothing away his glory will not go down after him
For though while he lives he counts himself blessed and though
you get praise when you do well for yourself.
His soul will go to the generation of his father's who will
never again see light.
Man in his pomp yet without understanding or wisdom is
like the beasts that perish.
So you see what's going on here, right?
The sons of Korah are looking around at the world
and their culture and they're seeing how
some we're trusting in their own wealth to deliver
them.
Now what do we mean when trusting and wealth? What does that mean? It means
that people were finding security and finding
hope in their wealth.
They were identifying their worth and their value by
how much money they have.
They were even assuming that they were Limitless.
Like I can do anything I want I can last forever.
So that's part of the culture, but then they're also looking
around. They're seeing other people who were Longing To Be
wealthy so they might be free from Death too.
Now really, I really want at the very least just Desiring to
be able to live that Carefree kind of life.
That wealth gives you everything you could ever want Hakuna Matata,
right? Everything is good and all my life is perfect.
Is that not happening around us just as much today?
Whether it's devouring page, six or People
magazine or TMZ or Entertainment Tonight, whatever
one you pick right we can so easily Envy
those celebrities lives.
or
maybe it's not that for you.
We observe people around us even in our area
here.
our neighbors our coworkers
driving nicer cars
living on the golf course or expensive Vacations
or whatever else.
And there's this subtle.
or maybe even potentially blatant desire
to have that kind of life.
To live as if we have no concerns or
cares in the world that we can live a perfect life that we're
really infinite. We can be Limitless. Look at what we can have and
do
If you've ever read John Bunyan's Pilgrim's Progress, what we're
talking about is Vanity Fair.
right
things all about image and portraying a
perfect life.
So that's happening around us even still but but further than
that people like we saw in Psalm 49 people are still
cheating other people to gain wealth.
They're boasting an evil excess and and
looking at how big we can get our yachts and
and all of these things are out there and other people are fawning all
over them telling them how wonderful they are because they're so successful
in business or whatever else they did.
It's what verse 12 and verse 20 call pomp.
which to OSU students at homecoming means one thing
To high school students graduating means another thing right? That
song is Pomp and Circumstance you walk into a graduation.
But that word pump merely means honor.
It's giving someone an apparently higher
status over others in that moment.
So these people look like they are
higher they are better. They are more valuable than anybody
else's.
Yet God is picking up the megaphone today.
To them at the time to us this first
universal truth. He's making it very clear wealth cannot
deliver from death.
Wealth cannot deliver from Death no
matter how much you have.
No matter how secure You Think You Are.
wealth cannot
deliver from death and pain and sorrow
now people try to thwart that all the time don't they?
We try to hold it at Bay. Keep it back there. We don't want to deal with
it. But the realities that death is coming for each one of
us.
Hebrews 9:27 it's appointed for man to die
once and after that to face the judgment.
Part of the deal now and remember that's not
just poor people dying.
Relatively poor people die. No those people
might think that if I can just get more wealth if I can get more stuff
if I can live like them then maybe I won't
be in trouble. Maybe I'll be safe.
No Ecclesiastes 9 says it's the same for all.
Since the same event happens to the righteous and to the wicked to
the good to the evil to the rich and to the poor death happens to
all of us. So the solution to that
is not gaining more wealth.
That's not the fix.
Because verse 7 said all the wealth in the world is not enough to redeem even
one soul.
So you can't redeem you can't save yourself plus you
can't take any of it with you.
Some of you have probably heard the old preacher joke that you
never see a hearse pulling a U-Haul.
Actually researching that this week. I did see a picture of a hearse of
the U-Haul. I almost showed it to you, but I was like, that's probably not best but
That's the point right the point here. You see it in verse 17.
When he dies He Will Carry nothing away. His glory
will not go down after him. No matter how glorious your life was.
It doesn't go with you.
You can't carry anything with you. In fact verse 10 adds not
only will you not take it with you. You'll actually leave it all to
other people.
Meaning it's going to somebody else.
That's why Jesus said
some piercing words in Matthew 6 about wealth
He said do not lay up for yourself Treasures on
Earth.
Where moth and rust destroy and where thieves break in
and steal but lay up for yourselves Treasures in Heaven?
Where neither moth nor rust destroys and where thieves
don't break in and steal for where your treasure
is there. Your heart will be also
No, one can serve two masters for either.
He will hate the one and love the other.
Or he'll be devoted to the one and despise the other.
You cannot serve God and money.
What Jesus is asking us there?
Is what is dominating your heart?
What is your master? What controls you what
are you serving?
What directs the decisions you make?
He says you can't.
You can't have both.
You can't serve both you can you can have money and serve
the Lord or you can have the Lord and serve
money.
He says which one do you want?
And you again you can't take it with you. This is
all gonna fall apart in the end. That's why I love what one author
put it. He said when considering this idea. He said you can't
take it with you. No, but you can send it on ahead.
So what does that mean?
You can't take it with you, but you can send it on
ahead what he means like Jesus said everything here is
going to break. It's gonna wear out. It's gonna get stolen or when
you die. It's gonna be giving away to somebody else.
That's why First Timothy six refers to it as the uncertainty of
riches meaning should not put your hope in something
uncertain like riches.
That means there are no sure assets here. It's all temporary. It's
all fickle.
But what that means is whatever you invest in eternity
will never depreciate.
It will never spoil it will never get stolen. It
is secure.
So what Jesus is asking us to do is to start
considering where we invest our resources?
Do you invest in the temporary fickle things and get stolen break
the stock market crashes you can lose it or do you invest
in something secure Eternal forever and ever going to
be valuable?
Pick that one.
Start treasuring Eternal things.
Like gospel Ministry feeding the hungry helping the sick
writing wrongs in the world on and on we can list out
hundreds of things focus on those things way more
than the temporary unsatisfying things.
We often focus on
you can't take with you. It's going to break. It's going to go away. It could
be stolen all of that.
Jesus says make a value judgment here.
We swim in the poison of
materialism here.
And one of the main antidotes to that is generosity.
Open-handed giving away saying I
can't take it with me. It's going to
go away. Anyway, so Jesus, I'm won't invest
this for your kingdom.
for your good
so I talked about last Sunday that nearly more than anything else.
Your view on money reveals your heart.
reveals your priorities
What am I focused on I could say
one thing. But if I live another thing it shows it in real
way.
So like Psalm 49 shows us here. You might consider yourself
blessed when you have more than other people do.
You might consider even others might
might praise you for your wealth and your success in business
and all of these other things that you've you've done well for yourself.
It says people say to us right and people might
praise you for all of that.
But don't be arrogant and think that the grave is
not your end as well.
Just like verse 20 said just like all the animals.
Riches, do not guarantee freedom from
sorrow from loss from death.
Death is the great leveler.
Right, no matter how much you have or don't have we all hit that
at some point?
and so now at this point you see why I started with
why I started is
Heavy distressing feels like Ecclesiastes,
like it's all hopeless. It's all meaningless.
But we needed to feel so Psalm 49 does
needed just to feel.
The weight of this that all of us are
facing this but what I'm about to talk about is what
I wanted to get to as quickly as I could in Psalm 49.
because for all the things that we've seen wealth cannot do
what we need to hear next is what God will do.
That yes wealth cannot Deliver Us
from Dell from Death. Yes.
But God will Deliver us from death.
You see where we're going with this now, right?
This is why we need to shouting this to each other. And
from God that God will Deliver us
from death. Yes death is coming. But verse 15
shows us a different outcome.
It says God will deliver Ransom my
soul from the power of Shield the power of death
for he will receive me.
He doesn't deny that reality of death.
I mean Sin from the Garden of Eden Adams
original sin means everything's broken. Every one
of us are on track towards death. Our bodies are falling
apart. The world is falling apart because of Adam's sin.
That is a reality.
And I don't want to.
Make light of that.
Because there's many people in our country this week even today.
Even people in our church this week facing the
reality of physical death in a very real raw
way.
And so we we know this it's heavy as we
face this we think about our own but then other people that we
love around us. We see these things happening around us.
but again for the believer
physical death, it's not the end of the story.
Yes, it's a reality but it's not the end of the story
remember verses 7 through 9.
Look again if Psalm 49 7 through 9 truly no
man. Can Ransom another or give to God the price of his life?
For The Ransom of their life is costly can never suffice that
he should live on forever and never see the pit again. No
one can buy their way out of this. It's coming for all
of us. We can't buy somebody else's way out of death. The price of
a life is far too high. Nobody has that kind of
money.
So we could not but praise God that he could.
We can't he can none of us could pay that
price. We're all sinful so I can't pay the price for your sin.
You can't pay the price for my sin no amount of
money could but listen First Peter 1 says you
are not redeemed with perishable things like silver or gold or
money, but with Precious Blood as of a
lamb unblemished and spotless the bread of Christ.
So it's not with money. It's not with anything else. It's
with the blood of Jesus in your place.
Nothing else can Deliver us from death?
no pleasure can
no anti-aging cream that you buy at 2AM off
the TV.
No religion, no good works. None of
that can save you from dying. That was
verse 7, right? No, man. Can Ransom another or give to
God the price of his life The Ransom of their life is costly that
is absolutely true, but man can't the
God man can't
Right, you see that?
It's just tracking through scripture. I'm just gonna read scripture. I'm
not gonna reference it. But this is just the track of what Jesus did for
us. He himself bore our sins and his body on the
cross that we might die to sin and live to righteousness giving us
Redemption through his blood the Forgiveness of our
trespasses according to the riches of his grace. He gave his
life as a ransom for many reconciling us to God through his
death saving us by his life purchasing purchasing
us with a price giving his life as a ransom. That's
what the God man could do that we could never
do
Okay, just making sure you got that.
That's what Jesus did for us
that we could never do for ourselves that
you could never do for me I could never do for you man. In
ourselves. We can't but the God man could.
and he did
but that's the point Church.
That's the point here is that you could do nothing to
keep death at Bay. It's coming for each one of
us. We don't know when it might be tomorrow. It might be 70 years from now.
We have no idea but death does not have the final word
for those who repented and believed in Jesus Christ and his work
in their place.
Because of that God will deliver from
Death those who believe.
It's what first Thessalonians 5 says that Christ died
for us.
So that whether we are awake meaning alive or
whether we are asleep dead we might
live with him.
Like whether we are alive or dead we live with him.
That's eternal life not physical life.
how
because Romans 6:5 says if we've been United with him in a death
like his we shall certainly be United with him in a resurrection like
his
because remember the father redeemed Ransom delivered
the son from Death not by keeping
him from death, but by raising him after death
First Christmas 15 says that's what he's gonna do with us who believe?
We are united with him in a resurrection like
his.
so again
Listen carefully Church.
death
for the believer does not have the final word.
It does not have the final say it is
not the end. Yes, your body
will give out. Yes cancer will rage tragedies
occur.
Babies will be lost. But for those who trust
in Jesus God will deliver them
from death.
And we can rejoice in that we can have hope in
that when we Face such hard times.
Now we could be done right there.
And be good, right?
We encouraged.
But this is what's interesting about Psalm 49 when you read carefully in
these things this whole discussion versus five through
20 talking about these two truths of wealth and death.
There's only one command in the whole thing.
All of these truths there's only one command and that command is
in verse 16 be not afraid.
Sons of Korah here are looking around at the chaos of
their world. They're seeing all of the trappings of the world. They're seeing
people live for the wrong things. They're seeing wealth does
not equal importance death does not equal the end and they result
with this command. They say don't fear.
When they have these truths in their mind.
The wealth is not important death is not the end and they
say as a result of that don't fear.
Verse 5. Why should I fear in times of trouble?
Why should I fear when people accumulate a lot or or attack
me or mistreat other people? I shouldn't fear.
Why because I can trust the future justice of
God.
That no matter how much of a celebrity they are.
How much money or power they seem to have no matter how much they seem
to be in in a higher class
than me.
Death is still coming for them, too.
If you remember Hebrews 9:27.
It's important for man to death to die once and after that
comes the judgment.
Meaning it doesn't matter who that person is. They are going to stand before
God just like you are.
Right that God will judge every
single person on the same playing
field here.
No matter what the glory of their life look like. It's all
coming down to this. One moment.
And so it's all going to even out. I don't
have to fear the world looking different. I feel
the way things are being done. The way people are living. I don't
fear that.
But then also the twin truth is that I don't have to fear death
myself anymore.
I don't have to fear because I know that's not the end of the story if
my trust is in Christ. I don't have to fear it I can face
it because he faced it for me.
And again, those are the truths. We need God to be shouting to
us to be reminding us of because when we look around
we see a whole lot of things going right we're tempted to fear every
single day.
Sure seems like the rich are getting richer. They're getting away
with it get in every way. They seem like they have no
consequence there. They're getting money at the expense of
other people look at how this is working.
Many people live in like their own touchable. They're infinite. They're that
they're there have this hashtag blessed life that because look at
what they've accomplished.
And we're tempted to be fearful and afraid of
what's going on with that.
But then even all of us listen, this is not just about everybody else
out there.
Even all of us inside of ourselves battle this
subtle demonic Force.
Where we long for what God has not given us.
And We crave
Because we're so discontent.
crave
new things
same day delivery
We crave like this is going to satisfy me this is going to
fill me and so we keep making Target runs to fill that hole in
our hearts
Right. So we're trying to to fill there's this subtle demonic
force in us saying you're gonna get that and
you'll be happy you're gonna get that and you'll be happy you're gonna feel that
and you're gonna be satisfied.
But this is where we can be different Church.
This right here is where we can be different. When we remember those truths
that neither wealth nor death has the final word.
That wealth doesn't equal importance death doesn't equal
the end. We keep that in our mind. It sinks into our souls.
We have nothing to fear.
Here's how we can be different.
That's how we can then live open-handed lives where we
know we can't take anything with us. So we Steward it all today for God's
glory.
We use whatever he's entrusted to us, whatever blessing financially
he gives us. It's for him. It's for others we
can see that this can be our lives reimagining our
generosity for his kingdom.
When we remember that we can then also at the
same time live lives free from jealousy and envy.
Because somebody else has more than I do.
We can live like that because we know that that's not where
true life is found.
Yeah, I don't have as much as they do but that's not true life. Anyway,
Jesus Is My Life?
when we remember those twin truths, they sing to
our soul we can live with no fear of even death because we
know that we know that it's not the end
that that
Jesus that we worship that we talk about
that he is on the other side and what
that means that there's a better life on the other side.
with the Lord
That's that perspective is how you can face cancer.
With joy and with hope knowing whatever suffering will
come is terrible, but you know what's on the
other side of it?
That's how you can even face old age with anticipation and
passion.
Where you see?
That you don't have to fearfully cling so much to
this world. You're gonna lose something. You're actually
gonna gain something.
What we're saying in all of this?
Is this is how you live out? What Philippians 1:21
says Paul says for me to live is
Christ and to die is gain.
That if I if I die.
If I die that that is actually better than
anything else this world can offer because I'm
Gonna Be With Jesus.
To die is gain now don't misunderstand me
in this.
This doesn't mean for you to accelerate your death, right? That's not what
we're talking about because God still has a purpose for you as long
as you are alive.
No matter what, you're feeling what you're thinking right now. He has a purpose for you. But
if you do die in his natural course of
whatever you face he is saying to you that's better.
In the end look you gain.
No matter how great it is in this world today. It is gain and
if you live
which all of us are until God takes us home. If I live
then my goal now becomes not just to stay
alive or not just to to be comfortable my goal
now becomes to live my life as Christ has lived
his life for me.
To live is Christ meaning life is
his it's all for him.
So whether I live or whether he takes me home.
have
joy
when this truth that neither wealth nor death has
the final word when that takes root in your heart. This is
the kind of shift. God will make in your heart and your life.
That you can live totally differently because I have nothing
to fear here and nothing to fear there.
And so unbeliever. Let me talk to you for a second.
If you don't believe thank you for being your first of all.
Keep coming.
but if you are honest
You know pain and death is coming your
way at some point.
You can't keep it from happening.
Nothing, you do can defeat it. You're gonna
have to deal with it at some point.
It's alive from the world that you will not stand before God someday.
So the question is what are you going to trust in when you
stand before God on that day?
What are you going to say? Here's what I got.
And it's going to be working. It's going to work. Is it your
wealth?
Is it your good deeds that you did enough good things and you're generous in
your life. And you weren't a jerk. Like is that what's you're gonna put up in
front of him?
Is it the your family and your story and
your history that you grew up in a Christian Hall? Is that is that what
you're gonna put in front of him?
You've seen it. None of that's enough.
The only way you will stand there and have any justifiable
reason to stay standing there is when you
trust in Jesus and his work in your place.
Nothing you can do to earn it. It's all Jesus
for you, and you must Trust.
That so don't trust in anything else.
But then believer, let me speak to you as well to me
myself.
I hope you see how this challenges us.
a couple of questions
Where are you misplacing your priorities in
light of these truths Jesus as
your joy and Jesus as your eternal life.
Put a different way.
What are you living for today? That won't matter anything
ten years ten thousand years from now.
What are you living for today? That won't matter anything 10,000 years
from now.
That when you stand around the Throne of Christ, it will not matter at
all.
That's the
temporary treasure Eternal treasure stuff
What are you living for today? What are you focused on
that looks no different than the values of
the world all around us.
Because that's the question if we have this eternal perspective don't you
think we should start living distinctly?
If we have an eternal hope if we have no fear in Life or in
death, then we should be living differently.
I should be living differently than my neighbors because
I have an eternal hope.
But what does that look like? Well Hebrews 13:5
prescribes a way for us as it says keep your
life free from the love of money and be content with
what you have.
Be careful.
Love of money is the root of all kinds of evil.
And we've seen what it can do. So be careful.
And be content.
But listen, that sounds pretty easy.
It sounds like okay. Yeah, I can try but
we live in this swim in this world of
materialism. How do I not?
It's because the rest of that verse says this.
Keep your life free from the Love of Money be content with what you have why for
God has said I will never leave you nor
forsake you.
That's the key.
That's the key, right?
So we say take an honest look at your life lay everything
before the Lord let him shift your
heart accordingly around his values live for eternity
not living for today don't walk with any
fear to give up anything. He would call you to right. Don't worry
about laying your life down for him. We use all
that language and we say that it's right and we should but
we look at that and we say how in the world. Can I ever do
that?
How can I give up my life? How can I count my
life as nothing for the sake of knowing it? How could I ever
be like that? You can only do that if you
know that he is better that he is with
you and that he's going to take you home someday.
You only can do that when you see him as the treasure
when you see him as the source when you see him
as better than anything this world can offer and
you see that your life is not the end.
Your death is not the end. Your eternal life is secure.
That wealth does not equal importance death does not equal the
end.
Those don't have the final word.
Your savior has the final word.
and that life he gives you
Not only starts when you die it starts today.
It starts that moment you trust him eternal
life is ongoing.
and forever
So let's live like it.
Let's allow him.
To show us to shout to us again and
again and again who he is what
he's done.
Let's not forget it. We so quickly walk out
of these doors. We walk away from his word every morning
and we forget it. Don't forget. He's shouting these
truths to us.
Because he's better because he is our
source and because he's taken us home forever with him.
Let's live like that.